il
passionné
artistique et motivés très précis
extraordinaire
gaston et ben on est chez moi
récemment installée à la réunion
j'ai réussi à adapter un petit atelier
pour accueillir les gens leur faire de
la démonstration de verre à chaud ça va
le cadre là pour le café
on n'est pas venu à la réunion pour être
sur une dalle en béton depuis
je viens régulièrement dans les
mascareignes en particulier a mûri cela
rouge et la moitié en famille
c'était élevé par une femme de là-bas
puis de timides qui de vous
mr
m
selon des proches de l'endroit de
soudure plus on a une précision le
village de mer est très précis pour un
sort d'un cadre on va dire d'un cadre
consommation il va de la société il va
vraiment rentrer dans une démarche
artistique où il va faire il va créer
des choses qu'il est tombé amoureux de
la réunion entre guillemets et que
vraiment ils s'adaptent au cadre de vie
qu'il est passionné qu'il est motivé par
la réunion une passion que je dévoile
aux gens qui commencent à me connaître
ou qui aimeraient mieux savoir d'où je
viens à l'origine j'avais un autre
support c'était la maquette de petites
voitures
le corps
où
tu es quelqu'un d'entier de qui va au
bout de ses projets qui a des idées
originales et film quoi c'est un métier
dont il est maître de a à z
parce que
il a créé son activité ça lui permet
aussi d'être ambulants indépendant des
fours ouais c'est un artiste mais nous
on s'est rencontré au 17e challenge des
nouveaux créateurs donc à la réunion
donc voilà on s'est rencontré à partir
de là et puis après on sait jamais trop
lâcher quoi c'est à dire qu'il vient me
voir mon jeu en fait je tient une
pizzéria sur saint joseph
c'est quelqu'un à découvrir déjà et puis
je trouve que ce qui fait aujourd'hui
c'est un sacré boulot
voilà donc c'est quelque chose de quand
même de beaux de très minutieux 500 eur
500 heures il m'a fallu cinq ans pour
pour la terminer elle a absolument tout
ce qui est possible d'imaginer dans une
voiture fine
- le créneau c'est de faire de la
miniature de choses faciles à
transporter qui filme à la poche des
bijoux de figurines des choses qui
restent
et ça me permets moi d'aller plus
facilement présenter ce que je sais
c'est une aspiration du quotidien en
fait l'inspiration de ce qui l'entourent
puisqu'il reproduit des objets réalistes
les objets qu'on peut reconnaître il
s'inspire de la végétation la faune
il doit y avoir je sais pas la louche
une centaine de potiers pour un verrier
c'est c'est un travail de la matière qui
est qui et d'une exigence très supérieur
aux passants
motivation
ce qui par je veux
pourquoi un autre
paru
et on n'a pas d'amis couleurs de
un peu d'artisanat d'art en fait il y en
a et on en parle peu à la réunion alors
restons il est arrivé avec c'est plus sa
plume et son soulier ses souliers
nous a fait ça fait quelque chose de
beau et donc voilà il ya très peu
d'artisans comme lui aussi aujourd'hui
qui font du filage de verre donc c'est
sur le vif quand on les rencontre sur
eux
sur le moment ça qui est intéressant
travail et on voit des fois les bijoux
on se divise pas possible si le
plastique ça vient de chine aujourd'hui
on peut poids 2 euros lui la déplie sait
même pas face et par rapport aux ordres
travail c'est du données obtenues sous
l'oeil du quotidien
plus de six mille ans d'histoire en
france
koné on affirme utiliser les âges et
c'est
la tire dessus
je lui souhaite pour l'avenir que
franchement ils se fassent connaître à
sa juste valeur par rapport à son métier
à la réunion parce que c'est quelqu'un
de fantastique tiers ouais ouais je
t'enverrai ifoto je le finis et je
t'enverrai une photo
et
un bon développement personnel dans sa
société et avec moi un bébé cheminement
classique
pouvoir
nationalement 2
j'aimerais simplement que les gens
continuent à me reconnaître
pour mon travail qui vous apprécient ce
que je leur propose ce genre on a